épinal dans la sphère du petit grégory
on s'enfonce chaque jour un peu plus
dans le drame
aujourd'hui le juge lambert a refusé la
mise en liberté provisoire de christine
villemin réclamée par son avocat et son
mari jean marie villemin
incarcéré à la prison de nancy a lui
aussi comme son épouse engagée jusqu'à
la fin dit-il
une grève de la faim sur place nos
envoyés spéciaux
marcel trillât thierry mais ni christine
villemin toujours en grève de la faim de
quittera pas le quartier des femmes de
la prison de metz queuleu où elle est
incarcérée depuis le vendredi dernier
ce matin à epinal tandis que la caravane
du tour de france se préparait pour une
nouvelle étape presque sous ses fenêtres
le juge lambert recevait m au garrot
venu lui renouveler sa demande de mise
en liberté provisoire de christine
villemin
sans illusion comment monsieur juge
d'instruction se déjugera deux jours
d'intervalle trois jours j'espère qu'un
non-lieu que la mise en liberté de
christine ça va soit ultérieurement un
non lieu en faveur de christine et enfin
j'espère que les preuves seront réunies
contre l'assassin et qu'il n'ya plus de
questions à ce sujet
midi le juge lambert plus sucrés que
jamais quitte le palais de justice en
apprendra bientôt pourtant qu'il est
resté inflexible que le procureur le
comte lui ai suggéré à nouveau de
libérer christine villemin et de la
placer sous contrôle judiciaire
il décide lui le maintien en détention
en début d'après midi nouveau
rebondissement du fond de sa cellule de
la prison charles iii de nancy jean
marie villemin entame à son tour une
grève de la faim entre le juge et les
villemin l'épreuve de force est
maintenant clairement engagée la
décision finale appartient à la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de nancy
qui a 30 jours pour statuer
compte tenu de l'état de santé précaire
de christine villemin
enceinte de cinq mois et demi et qui a
déjà perdu l'un des jumeaux qu'elle
portait cette décision pourrait bien
contredire celle du juge lambert les
hommes du commissaire andrieu de la
police judiciaire de nancy de leur côté
ont été chargés d'une nouvelle
commission rogatoire leur permettra de
bétonner comme on dit leur dossier un
dossier qu'ils jugent solides mais qui
comporte encore de nombreuses zones
d'ombré un dossier qui accable christine
villemin
mais sans aveux ni preuves formelles et
surtout qui laisse sans réponse la
principale question pourquoi